pour le moment il se sert toujours la
main anthony blinken et sergueï lavrov
esquisse même un sourire timide mais
rien dans la suite de leurs échanges
mais cordial très vite le secrétaire
d'état américain recadre son homologue
russe vis-à-vis de l'ukraine
nous sommes profondément préoccupés par
les plans de la russie en vue d'une
nouvelle agression contre l'ukraine si
la russie décidé de poursuivre la
confrontation alors il y aura de graves
conséquences un avertissement sans
équivoque alors que sur le terrain
moscou multiplierait les provocations le
long de sa frontière avec l'ukraine
selon kiev près de cent mille soldats
russes sont désormais déployés ici avec
chars d'assaut et artillerie lourde une
activité suspecte dénoncée depuis des
semaines par les occidentaux qui
redoutent une invasion imminente simples
exercices militaires rétorque que le
kremlin une réponse aussi à la présence
de l'otan à ses frontières
ces infrastructures de l'alliance
atlantique se rapproche de manière
irresponsable des frontières russes le
scénario cauchemardesque d'une
confrontation militaire est de retour
mais pour washington c'est à la russie
de prendre des mesures de désescalade
moscou de son côté demande des garanties
sécuritaires
depuis l'annexion de la crimée par la
russie en 2014 elle est de l'ukraine est
le théâtre d'une guerre entre kiev et
les séparatistes pro-russes
régulièrement des épisodes de tensions
comme celui ci éclate le chef de la
diplomatie américaine n'exclut pas la
possibilité d'un contact direct entre
joe biden et vladimir poutine dans les
prochains jours